pour
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
bonsoir j'ai apporté un beau jeu pour
jouer avec nicolas et pimprenelle ce
soir ma chère petite échelle
oui nounours veut leur apprendre à jouer
aux dames
mais c'est un jeu très difficile dit
suce hulot patron vous verrez c'est
enfantin difficile et pop pop pop bonbon
aux propos pro au soir mais petit
cheminot salut salut je le suis pas un
militaire serbe à moi j'ai un ami qui
dit salut et bien ce soir les enfants
je vous propose un jeu formidable
chicana c'est quoi ce jeu formida nous
allons faire une partie de jeu de dames
et voilà comment ça non non ça va pas
dans ta grosse cote
nicolien parce que tu parlais mal à mu
alors enfin nounours je dames c'est un
jeu pour les dom moi je suis un homme du
color beaucoup de messieurs très violent
jouault d'après nos filles mineures non
non et non
moi j'aurais pas ce jeu là c'est un
jeune fille c'est moi qui commence par e
mail je te montre comment on joue mes
pions ce sont les blancs et les noirs
gens en avance 1 avec prudence à et je
mange un tu mens après 3 aucune
importante à toi tu en avance 1 la trêve
et oui mais moi ma petite pape rhône
elle je tends mange encore à qui ça qui
gagne les noces celui qui a tout mangé
[Musique]
c'est affreux
j'avais presque à nu mais à ma petite
impro neige
[Musique]
de quel gros vilain
à nîmes nicolas vanier petite soeur pas
preneur pas preneur qu'est ce que tu
fais je ne tricherai plus si l'acte i
mashaal sable ne savait alors c'est
promis je ne tricherai plus jamais et la
prochaine fois pour faire plaisir à
nicolas
nous jouerons un jeu de cartes sont
bonnes nuits ne devraient petit jeu tu
as la lumière bonneuil north
[Musique]
nicolas a raison je n'aime pas les
tricheurs à vous voilà monsieur nounours
vous savez pas trop
oui et je ne suis pas content du tout et
si vous recommencez
je vous tirerait les oreilles je ne
toucherais plus jamais patron je le jure
et bien en route
bonne nuit les enfants faites de beaux
rêves à dos 1
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]